welcome to this video pause the red
posts every time okay maybe some Kings
Indian for a change okay the same and
i'm not exactly sure what I'm going to
do here mmm I'm looked at this guy this
kind of lions years ago with 97 and c5
okay now is playing this is very early
on maybe I can get some kind of banco
out of this out of this it's not so bad
the banco against this kind of setup 93
mmm that's early okay anyway yes to
develop me maybe i can go for be five
late night at d 7 a-6 setup is pretty
flexible that's one good point about it
so maybe gonna be five here
if he cancels yeah I'm going to take and
go 35 in case of Bishop takes which
looks very likely it takes Knight b6
yeah here and e5 or is that a bit too
bit too strong medicine maybe add a song
and so what am I going to do maybe take
Wow f4 that I did not think about it all
what's that good no that's not working
95 takes takes bishop jakes b 8 95 is
kind of interesting let's do that litex
context yeah and Bishop takes rupee age
text the bee pollen and a half Knight f6
going it's really active okay he just
gives me be too surprisingly see going
ibis should be three maybe hmm should be
three could be could be annoying really
hmm interesting Knight b6 is going we
should be three that's not doing much
actually I can take should be three no
yeah maybe maybe we should be seven was
my idea I'm checking fo I didn't really
calculate that correctly but it could
still be working well you can take b3 at
least one I have six maybe
that night we rupee three that looks
wrong hmm ok lied i haven't played too
slowly again
just care too slow so this one whoopsie
1mm between a five is a move moon I
don't really know that this Odyssey six
I mean you cannot take it yeah so Bishop
t5 is not working and maybe this kind of
thing this is this is quite simple
giving up the exchange should be okay
hmm I forgot about that move I really
did hmm okay it's still okay I believe
we should be five coming slide didn't
didn't didn't see that coming at all
okay I could have taken take a 244 very
simple draw okay yeah i was thinking
okay keep the Queen's on and try to
annoy him which is not such a bad idea
in general but it wasn't really
necessary at all f5s
looking tricky let me go here check the
rook time morning five hmm yeah I wanted
to go queen age 4 which is godrick age 3
m that's not really helping me I what a
stupid game I can just exchange Queens
and never ever ever ever lose the game
no no no I'm not doing that it just
really really bad bad blame
hmm not quite sure what is doing there I
mean it's better in almost any case but
you never five is a move check 13
seconds me so much for people play
quickly f5 is a move no check it's the
worst worst part of it is just playing
this really badly but it's still it's
still a problem and it was maybe maybe
this is it's probably still losing now
because now I have to know it's not
checking on the seventh which would be
much better check
okay anyway yeah ruku six resigns how
would y'all take care what a bad bad
game and just this this this and I can
never lose him just bad just thinking
okay let's try something the long
diagonal whatever but you can really do
nothing at this position with with with
black and yet many ways to improve of
course yeah this is some was very
interesting those complication see md5
e6 was interesting but yeah i already
had spent too much time and this is
probably not the best way of doing it
Queen d7 is the computer move if this
note taking is better because now we
have a double attack so Bishop t4s
prevented because of this mmm let then
that's much better and here I really
have to have to go for have to go for
for this line and now this is just
idiotic I mean kunia five is just oh I
played this pretty much instantly well
after this we pretty much can go home
it's just it just immediate draw Jim
yeah i know that i have i have those
times where nothing works and then no
somehow you get the rating back again
everything seems kind of okay i don't
know those kind of ups and downs and in
bliss chests are hard to explain anyway
thanks for watching